for
and uh as uh we were just hearing from
cordelia joe biden
has tonight been in the oval office
signing executive orders and taking
uh the first few questions from the
press pool there we see him let's listen
we signed a number of executive orders
over the next uh
several days a week and i'm going to
start today
the compounding crisis of covid and
kobe 19 along with the economic crisis
following that and climate
crisis and racial equity issues and
you know some of the executive actions
i'm going to be signing today are going
to
help change the course of the cove
crisis and we're going to combat
climate change in a way that we haven't
done so far
and advance racial equity and support
other underserved communities we're
going to rebuild our economy as well
and these are just all starting points
and uh we're gonna in the process of
rebuilding the economy
do what i said throughout the campaign
and while
running uh that uh rebuild the backbone
of the country middle class
and so there's gonna be a lot of focus
on that and uh i think some of the
things we're going to be doing are going
to be
are bold and vital and uh there's no
time to start
like today so uh what i'm going to be
doing uh
i'm proud of today's executive action so
i'm going to start by keeping the
promises i made to the american people
long way to go these are just executive
actions uh
they are important but we're going to
need legislation for
a lot of things we're going to do and
the first order i'm going to be signing
here
is relates to uh um
covert and uh it's requiring as i said
all along
um where i have authority mandating mass
be worn
social distancing be kept on federal
property and interstate commerce etc
so this is the first one i'm signing
[Applause]
and the second one i'm signing here
is the uh support for uh underserved
communities uh
and we're gonna already we've have uh
gonna make sure we have uh some
bedrock uh equity equality as relates to
how we treat people on health care and
other things that
you can we will give you copies of these
executive orders
[Applause]
and a third one i'm going to sign in
that's what we do while you're all here
is the commitment i made that we're
going to rejoin the paris climate accord
as of uh as of today
president uh wrote a very generous
letter i have it's because it was
private i will uh
not talk about it until i talked to him
but uh
it was generous
let's go